je suis désolé ryan entamé procès excuse
moi je n'ai pas protégé je n'ai pas
assez protégé des prêtres
non excuse pas tort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire de dina une adolescente
de 14 ans qui s'est suicidé le 5 octobre
dernier après avoir été victime pendant
deux ans d'harcèlement scolaire c'est un
déchirement le 5 octobre dernier
votre fille est ta soeur ryan ces
suicides elle avait 14 ans j'ai vu de la
lumière dans sa chambre il voulait
rentrer pour la la gronde et lui dire il
est 2 heures
et en fait
quand on en aa chambre à droite et à son
lit à gauchy à la revoir donc à droite
elle n'était pas dans son lit et j'ai
juste tourner la tête et je les trouvais
accroché à son placard
avec une ceinture
j'ai essayé de
de la soulager en fait je les priver les
gens j'ai appelé mon mari qui venu en
courant qu'il a décoché qui a commencé
les massages cardiaques
mais elle était déjà morte
et en fait elle a fait une première
tentative au mois de mars
donc elle s'est retrouvée à l'hôpital
pendant une semaine
et
elle recevait fin quelqu'un lui envoyer
un message en lui disant
on espère que la prochaine sera la bonne
là tout est raté mais t'inquiète pas la
prochaine sera la bonne et le collège
m'a dit mais c'est très grave il va
falloir porter plainte et moi je lui ai
dit oui je portais plainte contre les
parents des de ses filles et contre le
collège est en fait d'un moment où j'ai
dit contre le collège et ça c'est moi
oui voilà alors ma fille elle a repris
après son hospitalisation elle a repris
les cours et ça a été encore pire
qu'avant c'était encore pire qu'avant
parce que elle me disait même là c'est
peut être moi je vous même pu passer à
côté d elle parce que là me regarde de
travers où elle rigolé sur son passage
avec les autres les filles donc à elle
son brevet avec mention très bien l 410
sur 400 donc c'est incroyable et yves
dépassé j'ai tu vois malgré ton année de
merde tu as quand même assuré elle était
aussi traiter de sale intello parce
qu'elle posait beaucoup de questions en
classe
les élèves ne supportait plus en fait la
supportait plus quand tu fais pour aller
de l'avant aujourd'hui je vais pas de
l'avant j'y vais pas
elle me manque chaque seconde que
j'avais fait ma soeur me manque
on s'appelait tous les soirs
nous montrer comment elle et s'habiller
lendemain pour aller en cours
on faisait des lunchs times observer
lunch times ont mangé ensemble en amphi
stone vu que j'habitais pas à la maison
quand ça allait pas ma mère m'a demandé
de l'appeler je l'appelais se confier à
moi
j'essaye de rentrer le maximum les
week-ends et les vacances je passais
tout mon temps avec elle je faisais de
la musique avec elle on écrivait des
chansons chantées
je suis désolé rayonnante mais pro
s'excusant
non t'excuses pas tu exposes
ryan aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton combat
au nom franck j 6 à ma soeur dans un
premier temps je que ses harceleurs et
ses harceleurs el pais il paye pour ce
qui lui ont fait il m'a enlevé ma soeur
ils m'ont enlevé ma soeur j'ai plus de
serge en avait qu'une seule il me l'a
enlevé des jeux qui paie pour ça
[Musique]
tout agent qui après son élimination de
danse avec les stars samedi soir dernier
a décidé de disparaître subitement de
l'after de l'émission et des réseaux
lloris et en raison de son âge que la
jeune femme a dû partir je suis mineur
je ne peux pas être sur le plateau après
minuit et le seuil rumeur comme avec son
danseur alors on perdait alors enfin les
embrouilles ce qui s'est passé quand
même c'est carré beaucoup de tensions
autour de webzen depuis 2-3 prime moi je
l'attends moi aussi mais je vais la
défense si je dois choisir entre la
production good on sait que les stars et
britten choisirai toujours rester je dis
ce que wade n est en guerre avec la
production de gaz c'est pas vrai du tout
la première ayant été très déçue qu'elle
partait voyant origine une potentielle
gagnant ce qui lui arrive et c'est
qu'elle a une petite baisse de moral
comme plein de jeunes filles de son âge
et c'est à cause de ça qu'elle était un
peu en dessous sur les deux dernières
semaines de danse avec les stars en tout
cas il ya aucun problème avec la
production et c'est arrivé à plein
d'autres artistes donc il faut la
comprendre voilà vous voulez vendre quoi
que
moi je produis tf1 qu' vraiment
j'aimerais pas perdre les productions
bien sûr mais je pense que quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup de morale jamais et face de
toi bien réseaux sociaux mais toi tu
craques dans une longue histoire était
dans le cosmos non mais là
la balle sans évidemment évidemment
qu'il ya un problème elle était jeune
mais vous avez entendu ça ou à rungis
et vélizy les deux en même temps oui les
ragots ils disent qu'elle était jalouse
que tahiti y danse avec fauve hautot
qu'on le mettait en avant lui qu'on
mettait en avant bilal hassani et
qu'elles ont l'âme et au troisième plan
cas quand je suis fatigué vous me cassez
les ballons à la raison alors
c'est la star était
alors il admet les mecs regardez
regardez les
détails et c'est même la seule sa fille
à bichat
ce que je te trouve pas je te trouve
bien la tête était magnifique mais non
ça c'est grâce à qui grâce à trois merci
moyenne idées à tout en équipe je tenais
à tous à vous lire page 2 o et tout
franchement quand un chat avec vous
belge et la joie ça me donne envie
d'être avec vous en fait
c'est à dire il se passer quoi pourquoi
c'est à dire qu'il va adapter la boum
héros de façon à la libraire en fait
j'avais la boule au ventre mais tu début
j'en parlais pas avec mes parents ouais
ce que j'avais peur et tout à des ondes
c'est ce que tu nous avais honte et peur
oui j'avais plus peur pour aller parce
que je sais que mes parents si je le
redis vont pas laisser ça passait et
pour les représailles et thomas j'avais
très peur
moi c'est comme ça que je vois comme ça
et un jour j'en ai eu marre et j'en ai
parlé à que les gens en place tant de
social jeu du collège qu'a donc averti
mes parents comme j'ai dit à ma vielle
et foot chien c'est bon non ac c'est
vrai c'est malheureux de lire ça madame
a mais du charron connaître de sa
résulter de de sart frappé je suis
désolé c'est trop c'est probable peu
plus chez puma un jour je vais péter un
plomb en fait
c'est ça qu'on veut arrêter justement
les jeunes vont jusqu'à se suicider les
jeunes vont jusqu'à ce sont mes cd parce
que les gens ils se sentent comme ils
sont à plusieurs jeux quizz embête des
gens elle a fait rire la galerie alors
que c'est des merdes en fait moi je vous
le dit eddy merckx aux enfants [ __ ]
ils n'ont pas d'éducation ça c'est pas
mon problème à mes parents m'ont éduqué
il montera pas faire des choses moins
jeunes d'aujourd'hui comment si le thé
tout mais j'ai envie de dire mais tape
adjudication en fait pour moi ma vie
c'est ma vie d'un problème avec ma vie
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
[Musique]
dont clémence donne son anniv et alix et
la young claude qui vous regarde et vous
vous opiné du chef vous pensez quoi à ce
moment là vous dites c'est mort pour moi
ou vous ne rendez pas compte enfin bon
ça donne cette bande de bâtards
là là du tout sur le coup quand quand je
vois quand je vois que qui justement
qu'il me regarde je me dis ah ouais
d'accord donc là je pense que je viens
de comprendre que ça va être compliqué à
ce moment-là je me dis ah ouais ça va
être compliqué alors ensuite donc on l'a
dit il semblerait que tu ne t'attendais
pas du tout à cette alliance entre
certains candidats qui nous l'at il ya
un instant on va voir ton élimination
ainsi que les explications des
aventuriers j'ai voté contre toi pour
protéger alix
très bien avec elle est en danger
raconte puisque ma vie d'alexandre agit
non je peux pas le faire ouais je sais
ce que je dis le social ça paye pas et
là pour le coup j'aurais peut-être dû le
faire
[Applaudissements]
alors on va survenir sur le harcèlement
que les candidats subi sur les réseaux à
chaque diffusion le dimanche 17 octobre
devenu 21 combats réagi dans sa story
instagram la même tf1 qui réagit c'est
devenu un truc de ouf ça veut dire que
tu paies koh lanta c'est sûr que tu vas
faire insulter quoi rien mais sans
rigoler ça veut dire t'as pas trouvé une
amulette on prend pas de recevoir une
notification de combat et aqua ya une
demi-heure où justement il ya quelqu'un
qui insultait au moins un combat de
chappaz et aulas sait quel abruti
mais quelle bande d'abrutis ça aurait
sans rigoler fermez vos gueules non mais
sans déconner porter ces combats combat
vous voyez là m'envoyer lamvac jambe
droite s'est passé il faut porter
plainte grâce à ça on n'en peut plus de
ces abrutis sur les règles franchement
ça c'est insupportable vacheron et
généralement ces mêmes personnes qui
vous insulte quand ils vont prendre dans
la rue ils disent on peut faire une
photo exactement je sais je sais mais je
voulais c'est pour ça que ne pas enlever
ça mais je connais la frange écrit un
livre
insupportable qu'on doit juste laisser
passer non bien sûr bien sûr finale
s'est passé bien sûr coup est porté
plainte bien sûr c'est ce qu'il faut
macoumba coumé battu le mans sera très
fort de ma part tu
étais un se
situer de travail à proximité d'un feu
déjà d'une pourquoi parce que c'est
parce que ça peut provoquer des
accidents ou des carambolages adacore
oui donc ça faut le savoir je comprends
oui il faut le savoir ah oui tiens voilà
gens tous les sens du terme c'est le met
pas sur l'ondé de feu ou des croisements
on essaie de se mettre en retrait ou au
moins à 20 mètres d'accord les gens
aient le temps de s'arrêter rêvait déjà
de six arrêtés au feu on va en pleine
nuit il n'y a pas dix voitures devant
lui et c'est faux d'accord donc moi je
vous dis franchement c'est quoi
l'intérêt sur le c'est pas possible ce
qui l'a négocié peut-être qu'une passe
avec la fille il a fait le kéké l'a-20
est chez les fous de bonheur je gagne
des sous je suis pété de thunes il lui a
senti un billet de 50 balles mais il a
dû ouvrir un portefeuille et est arrivé
ce qui devait arriver je pense mais ça
je veux pas incriminer qui que ce soit
parce que c'est humain on travaille pas
beaucoup c'est galère en ce moment
à cette heure-là le club les brief c'est
une star internationale il a joué à
manchester united il joue au psg l'a
signé cinq ans le club leur dis faites
attention il ya des endroits où on va
pas donc c'est vrai que cette affaire
elle est bizarre c'est c1 ce serait un
hasard incroyable qu'à cet endroit là où
il n'ya pas y'a pas d'autres agressions
on n'a pas relevé récemment de plein
d'autres personnes en plus c'est vrai
que ça paraît quand même je ne préjuge
de rien mais ça paraît quand même
hallucinant il a dû au fait c'est à dire
qu'il a su comment s'affûter parce que
si là il aurait pas porter plainte il
savait pas futé ouais c'est ça que leur
gréement sa fuite et c'est pas là alors
gardons c'est lui qui a décidé de porter
plainte oui mais c'est parce que ça fait
un îlot il a fait un signalement à la
police mac pour pour se dé se dédouaner
je sais pas
avait dit tout à l'heure
justement comme il avait vu que ça
commençait à percer oui la péter klein
bruit
à percer à laurent qui portent plainte
signalement est porté plainte parce
qu'on peut faire un signalement mais pas
nécessairement porter plainte vous avez
déjà eu des relations sont cités avec
dédé des grands sportives ou des chevaux
oui relation tarifée oui oui oui ah oui
ah oui mais plein visiblement oui non
c'est vrai qu'on avait des genres des
directives politiques le
chanteur oui prenant à huawei
hommes de médias vous vous reconnaissez
les gens ici
les cars touristiques de deux chinois à
l'époque il passé dans le bois c'était
interdit parce qu'il se faisait
racketter sciences et aient volé les
montres dépouiller les apparaître et ben
le des sportifs du parc des princes on
le voir et m'ont dit c'est en orient est
pas censé être là parce que qu'on est
une assurance qui nous couvre du parc
des princes jusque chez nous mais si on
fait une altercation par le bois de
boulogne et qui s'il arrive quelque
chose au bois de boulogne on n'est pas
couvert il faut
savoir aussi c'est pour ça que je vous
dis il n'est pas passé comme ça
[Musique]
tous trouvent t3 surnom si tu étais une
star du x
la saucisse de strasbourg
fibres de boulbi et guillaume la tob
thiel
perdre
pourquoi
faire des choix
[Applaudissements]
sans lloris et transforme en
frankenstein
va d'une non mais ça va pas bien
vous êtes là on n'est pas
rationnel tu veux de l'eau j'en remercie
mais j'ai dit mais je leur donne oui
volontiers tu vois quelque chose tu me
fais pas quel peut-être un truc ici à
toi tu un truc à grignoter un bref ça
c'est mon nom perso à me faire du bien
l'autre volet
c'est à cette attention
[Musique]
vous
je voulais dire que cette scène m'a
choqué
manière dont ils sont là j'ai regardé
l'émission la manière dont ils
s'embrassent comment s'est montrée en
gros plan comme ça c'est alors il est
dit que j'étais bon diby sionisme et
de choquant deux personnes qui s'aiment
sincèrement qu'ils sont en train de
prouver qu'ils sont en train de
s'embrasser pour la première fois de
leur vie mais ce monsieur c'est la
première fois qu'il embrasse une femme
l'émotion là où on la ressent chez nous
il ya quoi que les dégradant en fait
c'est beau pendant c'est de l'exhibition
télévisuelle savons tous mais sa superbe
vous savez il ya un vieil adage en
france qui dit à rome fais comme les
romains donc à rome on fais comme les
romains à au maroc on fait comme les
marocains mais je suis
alors rachida merci d'être là rachida
vous êtes devenu une star aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parle que d'eux
pourquoi avoir accepté de rencontrer
eric zemmour va pouvoir m'exprimer tout
simplement ça lui ses idées ses idées
vous font peur non non non parce que
c'est vraiment des extrêmes c'est des
idées extrêmes donc c'était vraiment
pour avoir le personnage en face et il
vous en allez vous avez vous l'avais
trouvé sympathique j'ai l'impression
aussi des choses oui mais c'est ça qui
est grave estime louis sympathique mais
triste mais fallu sortir de trois d'arca
non mais attends on dit que vous ne
portiez pas le voile vous portez le
voile depuis quelques temps puisque
certains sont allés sur votre compte
facebook et ont vu que vous ne portiez
pas le voile alors le portait depuis
neuf mois c'est ce qu'a dit jean marc
marino depuis le début de l'année quoi à
tout casser d'accord qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous leur portez g voilà après
c'est une question de foi mais que
veulent les 10
j'essaie de me retrouver dans ma foi et
je commence petit à petit mais disent en
sélection et qui ont conclu à la mise en
scène ce qu'ils se sont dit tiens elle
portait pas le voile avant on a été voir
sur ces son compte facebook elle portait
pas le voile est maintenant le porte
peut-être que c'est le monde facebook
raconte tout n'aurait vu quelque chose
qui est embêtant mais je vous dis voilà
donc voilà ce qui résume en personne
attiré 110 exactement elle le port
depuis neuf mois donc voilà il n'y a pas
débat là dessus de la loi justement
failli il interdisait le port du voile
est ce que du coup vouloir dès février
ou est ce que vous seriez le pays qu'est
ce que vous feriez jusqu'aux libre mais
en imaginant c'est une question bien
même il a raison oui jamais qu'est ce
que vous feriez je le portais pas avant
quelques mois ça ne m'a pas empêché de
travailler d'accord donc là si on devait
nous l'imposé 6 à 2 il ya un texte de
loi qui devait voilà vous êtes une femme
vous devez pas porter le voile
j'appliquerai la loi comme tout le monde
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]